i can tell you what i went through which
is what set me on the journey um to
sharing the message
of the why and and uh helping people
find theirs um a y is like a is like a
it's like a compass direction it tells
you where you're going
we can live our lives by accident which
is kind of like getting in a ship and
just sailing
or getting in a car and just driving
you'll absolutely see some amazing
things you'll stumble
upon some amazing experiences but you
don't really have a sense of where
you're going any sort of
direction in other words what's it all
for what the why does is it provides a
path it provides a map or a compass
so you will still have some of those
amazing experiences but now they have
value and worth and they're taking you
towards something else
it's a journey towards something when i
learned my why
um i had this tremendous calm come over
me a sense of
my confidence grew um a sense that my
life had more meaning than i thought it
had before
and i had now the choice a new way of
viewing decisions a filter
through which to make decisions which
now i would ask myself does this help
advance my why or not does this help me
stay on the path that i'm supposed to be
on
or is this going to be a random a random
adventure
so the y provides focus direction
meaning and
and confidence